ja meine damen und herren dann begrüßte
sie sehr herzlich zum presseball heute
im robert-koch-institut wir grüßen noch
diejenigen die uns online oder über das
fernsehen zu schauen oder zu hören
heute wird ihnen professor schade der
vizepräsident des robert koch-instituts
kurz etwas zur situation und zu den
empfehlungen sagen
danach sind wie immer die fragen möglich
und am ende gibt es im foyer auch noch
die möglichkeit für sammel statements
bei bedarf können wir das auch gerne auf
englisch machen
an der stelle auch schon gleich dahin
weiß dass voraussichtlich am montag
dieser dieses pressebriefing nicht im
robert-koch-institut stattfindet sondern
das bundesgesundheitsministerium eine
entsprechende presse einen
entsprechenden pressetermin plant und
wir werden darüber war nochmal per e
mail an den verteiler informieren
das ist eben montag nicht bei uns
stattfindet und dienstag dann wieder
hier am gewohnten ort
guten morgen meine damen und herren ich
möchte sie zunächst kurz über die
internationale entwicklung informieren
und dann natürlich vor allen dingen über
die entwicklung in deutschland dann ein
paar hinweise geben was kann der
einzelne tun und anschließend steht für
ihre fragen zur verfügung
also auch weltweit hat sich die zahl der
fälle an dem neuen corona virus weiter
erhöht wir haben jetzt einen stand von
83 1300 patienten das sind etwa 1100
mehrere zum gestrigen tag und ich denke
eine zahl die da vielleicht
aussagekräftiger ist ist das eben auch
weitere länder dazu gekommen sind
inzwischen sind fälle verzeichnet in 52
ländern in deutschland sind uns seit
gestern über die
landesgesundheitsbehörden also auf den
meldet kanälen wenn sie so wollen 27
neue fälle gemeldet worden
diese fälle sind im wesentlichen in drei
infektions clustern wie wir das nennen
zu verzeichnen also ein cluster ist
umschrieben das ausbruchsgeschehen dass
eine cluster ist ja allgemein bekannt
dass ist in nordrhein westfalen das
cluster im land kreis heinsberg dann
gibt es ein zweites cluster das auch
schon länger bekannt ist in baden
württemberg dort hat es einen neuen
freigegeben der zu diesem cluster gehört
und es gibt inzwischen ein drittes
cluster das seinen ursprung
wahrscheinlich in münchen hatte aber
auch fälle in baden württemberg wieder
aufgefallen sind und in diesem neuen
cluster sind bisher vier fälle
identifiziert worden
weiterhin gibt es drei einzelfälle die
uns gemeldet worden sind 32 von diesen
einzelfällen haben eine einreise
anamnese nach italien und bei einem
dieser einzelfälle sind dazu ob du hier
eine reiseanalyse vorliegt oder ein
kontakt mit einem anderen fall bisher
noch keine informationen bekannt werden
aber selbstverständlich im weiteren
erhoben insgesamt zeigt dieses geschehen
dass diese neuen fälle eigentlich noch
ganz gut zuordnen bar sind bei diesem
einen fall müssen weshalb nach
herausfinden und das veranlasst uns ein
unsere risikoeinschätzung die auf
unserer website auch war uhr
veröffentlicht ist dahingehend
aufrechtzuerhalten dass wir hatten ja
gesagt es sind importierte fälle möglich
weitere einzelfälle infektionsketten
oder ausbrüche dass wir diese
risikoeinschätzung weiter
aufrechterhalten
das ist eben zurzeit kein breites
geschehen in deutschland zu geben
scheint und dass deshalb das risiko für
die gesundheit der bevölkerung gering
bis mäßig einzuschätzen ist was kann der
einzelne tun um sich zu schützen
ganz wichtig und man kann es nicht oft
genug sagen obwohl diese botschaft ja an
sich einfach ist ist die sogenannte
wussten und nis etikette das heißt
benutzen sie weckwerth bahre
taschentücher wenn sie niesen husten
oder niesen müssen werfen sie dann auch
anschließend wegwaschen sie sich die
hände
und falls das nicht möglich ist es ist
günstig sich beim niesen oder husten
wegzudrehen und in die ellenbogen zu
niesen oder zu husten
wichtig ist ebenfalls ganz unabhängig
davon ob man jetzt nächste oder hustet
sich häufig die hände zu waschen
häufiges händewaschen ist eine sinnvolle
und wirksame maßnahme darüber hinaus
möglichst abstand zu halten und ein
wichtiger punkt ist eben auch noch zu
trainieren möglich zu trainieren sich
nicht so häufig ins gesicht zu fassen
mit dieser weg von der reinen die
schleimhäute er möglichst reduziert wird
jeder mensch fast sich ein etwa 200 mal
am tag ins gesicht das kann man üben das
zu reduzieren und ein anderer wichtiger
punkt ist informieren sie sich bei
zuverlässigen quellen es gibt einige
sehr gute seiten
in der in der öffentlichen presse aber
auch die bundesbehörden bieten
entsprechende informationen an zb auf
der seite infektionsschutz punkt.de die
von der bz gerüstet ist weil der bch
selbst bei uns im robert-koch-institut
beim bundesministerium für gesundheit
und auch die landesministerien bieten
informationen an und wenn dann spezielle
ein spezielles geschehen ist wie zum
beispiel im kreis heinsberg ist es eben
auch wichtig auch die website und auf
die informationen der lokalen behörden
letztendlich zu gehen
ein wichtiger punkt müssen wir noch weil
wir das häufig gefragt werden was
empfehlen wir nicht wir empfehlen nicht
die nutzung von desinfektionsmitteln im
allgemeinen alltagsleben auch in dieser
jetzigen situation nicht und wir fällen
empfehlen ebenfalls nicht die nutzung
von gesichtsmasken und am mund
nasenschutz im allgemeinen in der
allgemeinen öffentlichkeit und im
alltagsleben
das sind noch zwei punkte die ich gerne
betonen möchte
ja dann würde ich gerne ja auch schon zu
der fragerunde über gerne herr
buchsteiner buchsteiner rd zwei fragen
weil ich das auch immer wieder gefragt
werde zum krankheitsverlauf wann kann
man mit fug und recht sagen so eine
infektion ist überstanden
vielleicht erstmal die also müssen da
unterscheiden zwischen dem normalen
unkomplizierten krankheitsverlauf der im
grunde wie eine erkältung abläuft eher
wie eine milde erkältung und hier kann
man davon ausgehen dass nach 10 bis 14
tagen dieser diese erkrankung
abgeschlossen ist man fühlt sich dann
wieder besser und die ersten
untersuchungen die es dazu gibt zeigen
eben auch das ist das virus dann nicht
mehr in den oberen atemwegen produziert
wird und nicht mehr verbreitet wird
es gibt einen teil der fälle der sich
nach dieser zeit nach etwa neun tagen
verschlechtert das sind die fälle die
dann eben die schweren
krankheitsverläufe haben
und wenn man so einen schweren
krankheitsverlauf hat dann kann es sein
dass man bis zur genesung 34 oder im
extremfall auch sechs wochen dass es
auch china beschrieben braucht das ist
aber nicht die mehrheit der fälle in der
mehrheit der fälle verläuft die
erkrankung mild und ist jetzt in etwa
80% bis 85% und ist dann nach 10 bis 14
tagen über stand 27 neue fälle seit
gestern wie viele sind es insgesamt und
bei wievielen können wie viel dieser
fälle können sie zu ordnen dass es sich
um schwere verläufe handelt also
insgesamt sind es in deutschland seit
beginn dieses jahres 53 fälle darunter
sind aber auch die 16 fälle wie schon
vor einigen wochen beschrieben worden
sind es war der auspuff cluster in
bayern da hat ja jetzt keine weiteren
fälle gegeben und die zwei repatriierten
fälle die sind auch mit dabei
schwere fälle sind mir nur bekannt
was auch durch die presse ja bereits
gegangen ist dieser dieser index fall
bei dem cluster in heinsberg der im
moment in der uniklinik licht herr villa
hatte ja gestern schon mal erwähnt die
ärzte sollten eigentlich wissen was sie
tun insbesondere auch die
niedergelassenen die sind ja wichtige
multiplikatoren sozusagen im negativen
sinne
ich glaube aber es gibt trotz allem noch
eine große verunsicherung des virus ist
neu wie ist es kann man den ärzten nicht
konkret eine empfehlung geben
handschuhe tragen mundschutz tragen
türklinken desinfizieren also
irgendwelche konkreten dinge damit die
einfach eine handhabe haben was sinnvoll
ist wenn sie eben verunsichert sind wie
sie in diesem fall umgehen können dass
die erste frage die zweite frage
betrifft blutspenden
sie haben ja hier auch die entsprechende
kommission im haus es gibt in hessen
glaube ich wurde wurde schon sozusagen
die blutspende eingestellt ja was würden
sie hier dann zu dieser situation sagen
ja also zunächst mal zu den ärzten wir
haben auf unserer homepage die hygiene
empfehlungen für den umgang mit diesem
virus veröffentlicht die sind erst mal
universell also die gelten für
krankenhäuser genauso wie für arztpraxen
und darüber hinaus muss man sagen
der arzt muss natürlich in seiner in
seiner praxis schauen wie kann ich das
bei mir anpassen
das geht eben los mit manche praxen
haben vielleicht die möglichkeit das
wären die ideale einen separaten warte
bereich zu schaffen oder auch einen
separaten eingang durch eine nebentür
das wäre im grunde eine ideale situation
man kann auch was gestern angesprochen
worden ist die praxis zeiten für
atemwegserkrankungen an die ränder der
sprechstunde legen oder einen ganzen
nachmittag dafür nehmen das sind alles
punkte wo man individuell schauen muss
da gibt es wie gesagt sie die
grundlegenden prinzipien was die hygiene
angeht sind auf unserer seite
veröffentlicht und es gibt inzwischen
auch absprachen mit bundesärztekammer
kassenärztlicher bundesvereinigung dass
hier auch noch weitere hinweise gegeben
werden
zur blutspende wir haben die kommission
aber die zuständige behörde wenn ich das
einfach so sagen darf ist das
paul-ehrlich-institut das
paul-ehrlich-institut ist diejenige
behörde die letztendlich festlegt ob
ausschlüsse von blut von der blutspende
erfolgen sollen oder nicht wenn man eine
bestimmte reise anamnese hat aus einem
bestimmten gebiet kommt in einer
bestimmten zeit und da kann ich
letztendlich keine auskunft geben müssen
sie ihre frage ganz korrekt institute
richten
markus feldmann
ki seitig sind auch empfehlungen
entwickelt wurden für angehörige der
feuerwehren polizei hilfsorganisationen
die ja unter umständen auch mit
potenziell corona infizierten personen
in kontakt kommen können ja auf unserer
homepage gibt's dazu ein eine
handreichung einen flyer der für
nichtmedizinische einsatz und
hilfskräfte beschreibt welche
schutzmaßnahmen aus unserer sicht
empfiehlt zu empfehlen sind gestern die
verknappung auf die der korona virus
sein tödlicher als die grippe ab doch
noch mal glaube ich zu wissen unruhen
geführt können sie das nochmal einordnen
ja das kann ich gerne tun
ich denke auch herr professor wille hat
das entsprechend eingeordnet das ist
dann etwas verkürzt da gegeben
wiedergegeben worden
also wir haben ja zwei
unsicherheitsfaktoren wenn wir über die
sogenannte tätlichkeit oder letalität
sprechen
der eine wichtige unsicherheitsfaktoren
die muss ich einfach betonen wenn wir
über diese zahlen reden ja eine
unsicherheitsfaktor ist wir wissen nicht
wie viele patienten tatsächlich
infiziert sind da gibt es verschiedene
schätzungen in china vizepräsidenten
dort tatsächlich infiziert sein könnten
und es gibt einige autoren die aus
bestimmten ja aus dem export von fällen
ins ausland rückschließen dass die unter
erfassung in china möglicherweise den
faktor 20 betragen könnte das also nur
fünf prozent aller fälle überhaupt
gefunden worden sind das ist die obere
grenze es gibt auch andere die das etwas
geringer abschätzen
eigentlich besteht einigkeit dass es
eine untererfassung gibt und dass die
fälle die wir sehen nicht alle fälle
sind die infiziert worden sind
das würde bedeuten dass diese zahlen die
man jetzt im internet findet um die zwei
bis drei prozent tätlichkeit dass die
natürlich dann sinken würden und auf der
anderen seite gibt es eben die
unsicherheit dass wir zurzeit noch nicht
wissen
bei allen patienten die jetzt in diese
statistiken auftauchen
sie sind sozusagen noch nicht
genesen alle da wissen wir noch nicht ob
die nun genesen optisch noch schwer
erkranken und wie letztendlich deren
krankheit im weiteren verlaufen wird so
dass von dieser seite auch noch nicht
ganz klar ist wie viele fälle sind denn
nun tatsächlich mit einem schwersten und
mit welcher weise auch einem tödlichen
verlauf es gibt von beiden seiten diese
unsicherheit und wenn man jetzt das ist
auch der grund warum die zahlen im
ausland außerhalb von china anders sind
oder könnte ein grund sein warum die
anders sind als in uk woher die meisten
fälle bisher vorgekommen sind
wenn wir uns jetzt mal vorstellen nehmen
wir einfach mal die zahl die im moment
für die meisten fälle letztendlich
kommuniziert wird von von den
statistiken oder aus der statistik zu
entnehmen ist zwei bis drei prozent der
gemeldeten fälle haben einen tödlichen
verlauf und wir gehen von der unter
verfassung von nur etwa zehn aus also
dass nur zehn prozent der fälle erfasst
werden also dass der faktor 10 sozusagen
da zu reduzieren wäre dann werden wir
wieder in einem bereich von 0,3 prozent
der tödlich kite und das wäre dann eine
starke grippewelle
aber ich muss auch sagen nimmt einen
gewissen unsicherheit ist das halt
behaftet es könnte auch eine sehr starke
grippewelle sein und es gibt ja auch
noch andere faktoren die das
beeinflussen wie es zum beispiel die
demographie in einer bestimmten
gesellschaft so dass man sich da zurzeit
einfach noch nicht festlegen kann
meine einschätzung wäre dass sich das in
etwa bewegt in der schwere wie eine
starke bisher starke grippewelle
früher frühauf mbr
der bundesgesundheitsminister hatte als
große herausforderung davon gesprochen
dass die infektionsketten teilweise und
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar wären
vielleicht können sie diese
herausforderung auch nochmal oder sehen
sie das ähnlich wie es gerade die lage
in deutschland
das ist natürlich eine herausforderung
dass das ist ganz sicher so wenn man die
infektionsketten den start dieser
infektionskette nicht nachverfolgen kann
das darf aber nicht dazu führen dass man
diesen fall und auch die folge fälle die
möglicherweise sich hier infiziert haben
also die kontakte dass man nicht alles
unternimmt diese kontakt nachverfolgung
trotzdem zu starten
es ist auch in anderen zusammenhängen so
dass es oftmals nicht gelingt jeden
krankheitsfall bis zu sagen ursprung
zurückzuverfolgen man weiß aber wenn man
dann von diesem fall ausgeht die
kontakte ermittelt die kranken personen
alle isoliert die anderen personen unter
beobachtung nimmt um den freiwillige
heimquarantäne zum beispiel das ist dann
gilt auch gelingen kann so eigen
infektionsgeschehen noch mal wieder
einzufangen
wenn man zb eine effektivität dieser
kontaktsuche von 80 prozent unterstellt
dann kann es gelingen auch dort wieder
infektionsketten so zu unterbrechen dass
dieser cluster zum stillstand kommt also
es ist eine zusätzliche schwierigkeit
das ist keine frage
und wenn mehrere solcher fälle aufkommen
dann wird die schwierigkeit umso größer
das darf aber nicht dazu führen und das
möchte ich hier ganz besonders betonen
dass man sagt jetzt ist eigentlich alles
zu spät jetzt können wir auch die
kontaktsuche einstellen und die damit
verbundenen aufwände die kontaktsuche
ist aus meiner sicht jetzt die
wichtigste maßnahme weiterhin auch wenn
wir mehrere fälle in deutschland haben
weil es eben auf jeden fall gelingt den
die infektionsfälle die dann von diesem
cluster ausgeben zu reduzieren und auch
noch gelingen kann diesen cluster und
weitere infektionsketten die davon
ausgehen komplett abzubrechen
noch eine frage wenn ich wenn ich darf
gott die sie sprachen davon dass der
infektions mittel und masken nicht
helfen würden oder wenig helfen würden
vielleicht nur die erklärung warum also
da muss ich natürlich unterscheiden nach
desinfektionsmitteln und den den basken
das ist ein bild des virus und seife und
wasser das reicht ja das reicht im
normalen alltag aus das ist für die
händehygiene sowieso und dann gibt es
natürlich noch die möglichkeit der
flächen desinfektion die wir auch nicht
empfehlen im alltag nur im
patientennahen bereich wenn der patient
erkrankt ist zb im krankenhaus dann ist
das eine empfehlenswerte maßnahme weil
einfach die die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man irgendwo auf einen virus trifft das
noch aktiv ist das dann mit der hand
aufnimmt und sich irgendwie dann poliert
zum beispiel in die schleimhäute des
auges oder der der hand ohnehin nicht
sehr groß ist und wir wissen dass die
maßnahme händewaschen eben diese an
diesem weg unterbrechen kann die maske
die masken
es gibt einfach es gibt keine dass es
mehrfach untersucht worden es gibt
einfach keine wissenschaftliche evidenz
dass das irgendeinen sinn hätte
wenn keine weiteren fragen sind so dass
nicht unnötig in die länge ziehen dann
danke ich mich ganz herzlich und
erwartungsgemäß bis dienstag dann auch
wieder sehen